hello everyone
and welcome to today's broadcast
microbial identification
and confirmation using the broker maldi
biotyper
the contract laboratory perspective i'm
alexis cross of labberts and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lappers
and sponsored by brooker deltonix for
more information about our sponsor
please visit their website at
brooker.com
so let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click on the send button if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
please report your problem by clicking
on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
i'd like to now
introduce our presenter wesley thompson
a microbiology research
and development group leader at q
laboratories in cincinnati ohio
for a complete biography on our
presenter please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen wesley welcome
sir you may now begin
your presentation
thank you for that introduction and let
us
jump right into the presentation hello
everyone
thank you for joining me today for this
webinar my name is wesley thompson
and i am the group leader of the
microbiology research and development
laboratory
at q laboratories which is located in
cincinnati ohio
q labs is a contract testing laboratory
with both
analytical and microbiological
capabilities for third-party testing
needs
i personally have been at q labs for
over 10 years now
but the company goes back farther than
that
qlabs was founded in 1966
by a png scientist who was actually
conducting microbiological testing on
water in his very own basement
over the years we acquired ownership
from a former fda investigator as well
as one of the first employees hired on
to our chemistry department
in 2017 a group of cincinnati investors
acquired
75 ownership and we launched the
greatest expansion in qlabs history
a year later in 2018 we opened a brand
new
30 000 square foot lab building to go
along with two other
existing buildings on our campus
two labs has many accreditations
certifications
and achievements making us a top-tier
testing laboratory
we are the only laboratory in north
america to be
a certified expert laboratory for
microal
and afnor in regards to validations
and we are also the only cdc elite
certified laboratory in ohio for
legionella testing
we have a vast array of analytical and
microbiological capabilities
which allows us to assist our clients
with any of their testing needs
so now that you have a little history on
our laboratory
i'm going to dive into our discussion
that you are here for today
microbial identification and
confirmation using the broker multi bio
typer
and we have three objectives that we're
going to cover today
first i'm going to give you the
perspective of the contract laboratory
and their role in routine testing
specifically for identifications and
confirmations
second i'm going to discuss how the
broker multi biotyper is
one of many offerings to discuss for
clients
to meet their needs and characterization
of isolates
and finally we're going to kind of cover
the certification process
for new technologies like the biotyper
and the impact that it can have on the
laboratory
so for those of you who may not be
familiar with mollitos technology
that's kind of give a general overview
of how the broker multibiotyper works
in terms of identifying bacterial and
fungal isolates
the general preparation is quite simple
in design and it allows for a very high
throughput of samples
so first we'll take our auger plate
that has isolated colonies bacterial
fungal
in origin and then they will be
transferred
to our target plate that you see here
that target plate
will then be placed into the instrument
where we will
acquire our profile spectrum
that profile spectrum will be pattern
matched to the database provided by the
broker software
and then we'll get our result and
from prep to analysis we can usually
run about 96 samples in 60 minutes
so just in general this kind of shows
that the the process from start to
finish is very easy
it's faster than conventional techniques
we'll dive into this a little more but
it is very cost effective
and these identification results are
very comparable
to sequencing
so what does maltitoth mean
monitor stands for matrix assisted laser
desorption ionization time of flight
now what does that mean in terms of a
workflow well
let's let's break that down for you an
isolated colony
is transferred to a target plate that
you see here on the left
side of your screen and then a matrix
solution is going to be overlaid on that
spot
which creates a lattice structure which
is shown at the bottom
of your screen here and that's going to
be a very important for our next step
the next step is the nitrogen laser is
going to hit
one of their spots where you have that
lattice
structure and energy is going to cause
desorption
of the proteins on that target plate
while simultaneously ionizing them
and it's this ionization that creates a
positive charge on the proteins
which is very important for the final
step
of this process top or time of flight
is the final stage and it occurs due to
the negatively charged panels that are
on each side of the flight tube
and what this does is it accelerates the
positively charged proteins
up the flight tube to the detector unit
during this time of flight the proteins
are going to travel
at different speeds due to their mass
and that's going to cause them to reach
the detector at different times
these varying masses and times are what
will give us a clear spectrum
of what the organism is in our sample
here's an example of what the spectra
will look like for
a given organism this one specifically
is for e coli
and this spectrum is going to be
pattern matched to the library that
broker provides in their software
and give us an identification
now results are very easy to interpret
so the graphic on the top of your screen
shows you what a report will look like
it'll have your sample position
how you labeled your sample the
identification
that the software will give you as well
as a log score that is color coded
the graphic at the bottom shows you this
traffic-like color schematic
that broker uses in order to
interpret results so it's very clear to
see
what kind of level of confidence you
have for your identification
so now that you have an overview of the
process
and the technology uh let's continue on
to how this can be implemented into a
contract laboratory
and how this can change the way
identifications and confirmations have
traditionally
been conducted so the two laboratories
we have two separate routine
microbiology labs
one for food testing one for gmp gmp
pharmaceutical testing and both of them
include a wide range of samples being
tested
anywhere from raw materials to finished
products and everything in between
so when an excursion does occur during
testing
this is going to cause a client to hold
products
before release until they can make
certain that their products are safe for
the public
so now any every second that a product
is being
held clients are losing money meaning
that they want their results as soon as
possible
again this is where the bio typer will
come in
another area that's slightly outside of
these two routine laboratories
are agricultural products many
agricultural products
have specific species of bacteria
and fungi that are beneficial
insecticides
or they might help promote plant growth
and these products need to be tested to
verify that any species that's on a
client's claim
are present in that finished product so
these are just a couple of situations
where the biotype can be utilized to
save time and money
not only for us as a contract laboratory
and but as
for a client as well and we'll go into
some more specifics with that
in a little bit
so what does the biotyper have
in a contract laboratory well
identifications and confirmations are
not only
important for pathogen testing but also
areas such as identification of spoilage
organisms
and for data trending for environmental
monitoring and
processing plants most people tend to
think of identifications
as a final step in testing
[Music]
you know you start with a screening
method we get contamination and then
we're going to go straight to
identifications
but sometimes
an identification can be the first
thought for a client when they're
noticing that their
bottles of salad dressing are swelling
or they see something in their eye cream
another time that identifications are
the first go-to
are probiotics which are very big in the
industry now
and clients need to verify that
whichever species
of probiotic that they're using whether
it's bifidobacterium lactobacillus
bacillus coagulants etc
is in their product and so they're going
to go to identifications for that
so now let's move on to um our second
objective
of the day and
discuss how the biotyper is one of many
offerings
being discussed to clients to meet their
needs and the characterization
of isolates
so when a client has a product a fail
specification
typically the next step is to determine
what the organism is
and this can be accomplished in a myriad
of ways
and it's important to determine what
information the client needs
you know we need to ask what's the right
tool for the job
so any technology that's going to be
used for an identification or
confirmation is going to be needed it's
going to need to be
validated and it's going to have to have
the right certifications
the biotyper has gone through these
validations
um and is an approved technology for
both the us
following aoac guidelines as well as the
eu
following guidelines by microval and the
eu regulation
for microbiological criteria for food
stuff
it also follows isis 16140
and it's been validated for
client-specific
methods to be used for identifications
and confirmations now
the biotyper is not the only
identification technology out there
and it is important to note that they
all still have a place
in terms of being needed but it's just
dependent
on what information that our clients are
looking for
so traditional techniques still have a
place for many reasons and that's
due to the fact that proteomic proteomic
identifications
using the broker multibiotyper can still
have difficulty
properly distinguishing between closely
related species
so for instance e coli o157 h7
is very closely related to shigella
species
because of this proteomic means of
identification
will not work so we have to go the more
traditional route of biochemicals
and serology which leads us into the
other situation that comes into play
serology
the broker multibiotyper is not capable
of stereotyping
isolates like e coli and salmonella
so again these traditional means are
still going to be utilized
in other instances clients require a
sequence based id
using 16s sequencing
so therefore because of their
requirements they won't be able to use
the buyer's paper and will have to go
to some of the the other means of
identifications
something that i will touch a little
more on later but i'd like to hand out
here is that 16s sequencing
is still vital for the buyer typer
because that is one way in which
um broker as well as clients are able to
add and update um the library of spectra
for the future um and finally for this
all technologies must align with any
quality system
set in place um so in
for instance iso 17025 accreditation
and that's going to go with any
technology that's going to be used for
identifications or
confirmations
so when a sample does require
identification or confirmation
we have to ask ourselves what are the
true needs
of our client are they looking for a
root cause
is this due to a recall are they
doing research or is this just simply
curiosity
because they found something and they
just they just want to know what it is
all of these are going to change the
information
needed for the client
another way to determine
what the client needs is going to be
asking what kind of turnaround time
do they need sometimes the client's
going to go i need this
id yesterday or they might say you know
it
they only need a couple days well that's
going to change
what technology or technique is going to
be able to be used for identification
because each one has its own timeline
and cost a client is not going to want
to spend a bunch of money
for a result that may or may not give
them the answers that they need
so there's many techniques for
identifying organisms
and each one is going to give you
various levels of information
they're going to take various amounts of
time to get those results
and it's going to cost varying amounts
so clients are going to want to spend
the least amount of money
for the most information that they need
and all this is imperative to know
up front so that you know we can
determine these solutions in the end
and that they are easy and cost
effective for the laboratory
and for the client
so screening a product for contamination
testing for pathogens
it can change the end result needed many
times screening a product for
contamination will result in
identifications just dependent
on the method being tested or the
information needed
sometimes just due to a failure of
specification
so how can this vary well depending on
the product type
that a client is testing that's going to
depend on
what kind of information they're going
to need on the back end others can be
dependent on the method being used
each method can require various levels
of information
and the client is going to have to
follow that as well as the laboratory
there's other things that factor into
this are regulations
um they can require a specific level of
identification
again based on product type or the
industry
in which this product is going to be
released so
like i said each one can require various
levels of needed information
which can change the identification
technique so it's
important to know a lot of this up front
so that you can get as much
detail as possible to make the decision
easier
and once we have determined what
information we
need then we ask what technique
will get us there
so at q laboratories we kind of
streamline this process
to make it easier for the labs and for
our clients
so here we've developed our own
identification laboratory to centralize
this process
for all the labs on campus so when a
routine lab
or a client has a direct submission
of an isolate that they want identified
it's going to be transferred to our
microbial identification laboratory
where
we can then determine what the best
process is for the information needed
so this diagram that you see just kind
of shows you
all the samples at the top coming in
from all the labs or clients
directly to our identification
laboratory then we're going to be able
to determine
what information they need and what the
best technique
and method for identification can be
used
sometimes it can be as simple as a
microscopic evaluation
the client might just need to know is
this a gram-negative or gram-positive
is it a yeast just very simple
means of identification whereas
sometimes
clients need a little more information
they need to know the genus they need to
know the species
and that's when you're going to go
farther up this ladder
in in terms of biochemical analyses
the moly tough like the buyer typer
analyses or 16f sequencing
so now that we know that there are many
avenues that can lead us to an
identification
how do these new technologies such as
the broker molly by paper
get a seat at the table well in order
for a new technology
in this case the buyer typer to become a
routine laboratory asset
it must first be validated to prove its
equivalency
and or superiority over traditional
methods
and this validation allows for it to be
an approved instrument
for identification and confirmations
according to certification bodies such
as the aoac
or microvalve
so in 2017 uh roughly
six months after q laboratories acquired
the instrument we assisted in conducting
the aoac
official methods of analysis validation
for the use for confirmation of
pathogens in food samples
and the way this certification
went was that there was a gram-negative
oma or official method of analysis
and it targeted specifically salmonella
and cronobacter
as well as some targeted campylobacter
species
and it also had non-target gram-negative
organisms
for the gram-positive oma it focused on
listeria species
and listeria monocytogenes as well as
other non-target gram positives
and what this did is it allowed for the
certification to include these main
pathogens
that are typically recovered in food as
well as to be able to identify
other similar species that can also be
typically recovered in food that are not
pathogenic during
this oma it also included various augers
to show robust robustness of the method
and what this did was it allowed for
laboratories to have flexibility
during culturing whether it was because
of the method required a certain auger
or whether
that laboratory preferred to use a
different auger
it allowed them to have some variability
and finally to show reproducibility a
collaborative study was conducted with
multiple labor
laboratories led by two expert labs
adria which is located in france
conducted the interlaboratory study for
the listeria and salmonella portions
of the interlaboratory study while q
labs
in cincinnati ohio conducted the
chronobacter and campylobacter portions
of the interlaboratory study
it was in 2018 after all this was
completed and approved
that broker actually was awarded
the official method of the year from
aoac
so how are buyer typer results
different from other identification
methods
well as you saw in
the first couple of slides uh the
results are very easy and they're
accurate and
it's the interpretation leaves little
room for error
um and this is the this is important for
both the laboratory
and the clients uh the biotyper allows
for this easy interpretation
um for the analysts in the lab and for
our clients
there there's no need for this in-depth
knowledge of bioinformatics
or years and years of schooling
studying sequencing to achieve
this understanding of the result and it
allows
us to be able to clearly explain and
let it be clearly understood by
non-technical people
we all know working in the laboratory
makes us understand these results a
little easier since we're working with
it every day
but for many of our clients they don't
have a background
in what we do every day and it's
important to be able to explain these
results to them
in a way that it's not complicated um
it's not overly specific or in the weeds
but at the same time we need to be able
to assure them that these results
are accurate even though they're very
easy to interpret
so whether you're talking to someone
with a phd
a person in operations or simply a new
hire
at your job these results
need to be clear and accurately
understood
and broker does a very great job
presenting that this is also very
important when taxonomic
taxonomic changes occur so for example
a couple of years ago the organism
enterobacter erogenese
changed genus to klebsiella
now many people would not may not
realize that that occurred
but since enterobacter erogenese was
used as a control organism
for a few methods when it changed some
clients are going to look at that
and see klebsiella orogenies and not
know what it is or
be expecting enterobacter rajnees and
get klebsiella rajnees
well they don't know what that is well
it was
it's important for us to be able to
explain that but also
it's important to point out that
brooker maintains their database and
updates it
along with their software routinely
following
fda 21 cfr part 11 compliance for
electronic systems and documents
which allows for any
organism taxonomic changes to be
documented
and updated um every year
it's also important how these results
are presented to our clients
so another nice feature of the brook
remotely buyer typer is that reports can
be customized
not only for our laboratory but for our
clients it can be based simply on
what isolates they need on a specific
report
but also we can add custom images or
a client's logo to that if if that's
something that they require
and as discussed a little bit before uh
the broker multibiotyper has the
capability of a customized
database um and this is huge this this
allows for the addition of
any isolate that's not already in the
library
commonly identified organisms in a
laboratory or production facility
can be very important for future testing
whether it's challenge testing or qc
testing
and with the biotyper we are able to
sequence these isolates via 16s
sequencing and then
add them to the library so that we don't
have
not reliable identifications in the
future for these isolates
because as many of us may know wild-type
isolates can be finicky
when conducting identifications whether
they're automated or traditional
and this capability helps to just build
a more robust library
and prevent any issues in the future
so now from a contract laboratory
perspective
i'd like to show you how the broker
multi biotyper
has changed our workflow
so while traditional means of
identifications and confirmations
still hold a place the implementation of
the biotyper
into our laboratory has significantly
decreased our volumes
of these traditional methods and
q labs acquired the malditof back in
august of 2016. and so what you can see
here on these graphs
is the decrease in the number of
traditional
tests and methods we use for
identification
as well as it shows the increase in the
biotyper identifications
that we've had over the past four years
so it has drastically changed the way we
conduct identifications here at q
laboratories you can see simply our gram
stains have decreased
biochemical analyses decreased
sequencing decreased but all through
that time
the biotyper identifications were
increasing
so now that we have an overview of the
technology
and understanding of implementing it
into the lab
and how it's improved our workflow let's
just go through some strengths of the
instrument
so the biotyper it's the fastest most
straightforward way for us to obtain a
microbial identification i mean it's
it's nearly always higher quality than
the traditional biochemical id
um and again fast you'll hear this
over and over from people who have a
molly top fast fast fast
a quicker time to result is what
everybody wants not only laboratories
but clients
it has a comprehensive library so you're
not going to get
a lot of no identification results
and that's really important when you
have a high throughput lab
pumping out identifications and
confirmations
on top of their general library they
also have an additional subtyping module
that can accurately distinguish between
some closely related species
so specifically here you can see there's
listeria species like a bacterium
species
and that that was a huge one for us at q
labs especially in our food
microbiology laboratory um for when
we're identifying listeria species
because in that area a lot of clients do
want to know
exactly what species that they have and
this subtype of module really came in
handy
and since the sample preparation is
conducted manually by an analyst
it's not automated it is possible that
sometimes you might not be able to
evenly coat your sample across your
target spot
and the broker allows for you to
manually focus
the laser on your spot so what does that
mean
well if you have a poor or uneven spot
you can see it
from the camera and able to
move that laser around to a
better area of the target to get high
quality spectra
to make sure you can get an
identification
so there are actually three sample
preparation methods
for the maldi tof and
this allows for you to almost guarantee
that you get a collection of good
spectra for identification
you can typically get an identification
from
[Music]
using one of these or all three of these
methods
um as again as we've touched on before
the ability to add to the library
is a key feature of this technology the
software is user friendly
and it makes the additions very very
easy
but something else that's very
nice with this software is that you can
actually
share libraries between laboratories
currently the cdc has its own pathogen
library
that can be used by anyone with mass
spec identification capabilities
so a user can run an isolate in their
facility
and then upload that spectrum to the cdc
website which i've provided the link
here
and it will compare it to the library
that they have for free
so that's always beneficial
so another strength is that with
traditional techniques
there are usually more consumables and
more supplies which
is costs more money costs more time
but with the biotyper these are
significantly decreased
it saves so much money but more
importantly so much time
using the techniques here
and finally the technology allows for
the identification of older cultures
which is huge many biochemical analyses
require
fresh growth from you know 24 to 48
hours old
but with the biotyper here at q
laboratories we actually validated it
running different ages of cultures and
for bacteria nice we were able to
identify a culture that was
five days old and for moles
up to seven days old so that definitely
helps in terms
of you know turnaround times
or running into any issues in the lab
um you don't have to just have this
day-old growth if it has to if it's two
days old you can still get an
identification without having to spend
more time and resources
on a new subculture or a new isolation
street
so with a lot of technologies there's
always ways in which they can be
improved and
although the broker has a few they are
continually working on development to
strengthen their instrumentation and
software
so here are just some of the areas that
we believe
the broker could use some improvement
based on our experiences so filamentous
fungi have always been kind of hard to
identify
in the laboratory unless you're a
mycologist
but the broker has allowed us to be able
to identify
these filamentous fungi well
the struggle here is that the library
isn't quite as robust as the bacterial
library
but again they are continually working
to update their libraries
there's typically an update every year
with the additional isolates for
bacteria and filamentous fungi
another area due to the complexity of
this instrument
there is not many troubleshooting
capabilities at the hands of the user
um you know if there's anything wrong
with the software or with inside the
instrument
beyond a source cleaning or removing you
know
visible dust you know it's going to
require
a broker technician the nice thing
is that broker's customer assistance is
very quick to respond
and they can usually remote in to
conduct and
laser optimization or troubleshoot any
of the issues
but again not much you can do on the
side of the laboratory
and then lastly something that we've
already kind of discussed
is that traditional techniques are still
needed for organisms that are closely
related
such as bacillus species broccold area
species in the complex and anaerobacter
complex
and the r d team is working on these
like i said they have that subtyping
module but that's still just an area
that of continual work that we have will
improve
over the years
so with the details we've covered about
the biotyper
and traditional methods let's let's take
a quick look at a comparison between the
biotyper
and traditional biochemical analyses
so just you know the differences here we
have the biotyper which is proteomic
identifications
biochemical obviously biochemical
identifications
the broker has a quicker time to result
say 30 to 60 minutes versus a
biochemical which is 24 to 48 hours
and sometimes even longer than that
with the biox hyper no gram stain is
necessary
biochemicals you do need a gram stain
right there you are completely
eliminating a step which eliminates time
and resources needed
um the biotyper is capable of
identifying molds
whereas biochemicals you cannot um
biotyper like we said the cost of
consumables per id
is significantly lower than biochemicals
which is great for the lab and for the
client
and finally and probably most important
accuracy
the buyer typer has a lower rate of
false identifications
whereas biochemicals you have so much
subjectivity
that can vary analyst analysts when
looking at these biochemical reactions
if it's an automated system they have
typically a less robust library
and overall a higher rate of false
identification
so this kind of shows you the difference
between the biotyper and by traditional
biochemical analyses
for us the broker has become a staple
in our laboratory it's it's completely
revolutionized how
identifications are conducted um and now
i'd like to just give you
some examples of you know specific
examples
here at q laboratories where the
biotyper has been such an asset to our
laboratory
so we'll start with case study one who's
to blame
so we had a client send in samples for
testing
and after you know the proper incubation
times and enumerations
it was discovered that this product
failed
the client's specifications so they
wanted ids
well these isolates were recovered and
identified as a chloralobacter species
the immediate thought in a client's mind
is typically it was the laboratory's
fault they contaminate our sample
there's no way it could possibly be us
well many non-sterile manufacturers
tend to forget that their environment is
not sterile
when during production but from a
laboratory perspective we too want to
make sure that we are not contaminating
and cross-contaminating samples when
we're testing
so with the burger multi bio typer we
are able to
quickly take a isolate
off the plate run it on the instrument
and have an identification in you know
10
15 minutes and we can say you know what
it is
and because of that we are able to test
multiple different samples so
we discovered that other samples that
this client had sent in
had also found specifications we were
able to identify them quickly
to show that they were in fact coming up
as the same
species well because of that and because
of the quick turnaround time
we were able to look back again at other
samples that
maybe didn't fail specifications but
they
still had some contamination well
we went ahead and i did this and found
out that those two
were the same species of pleuralobacter
as the samples that failed specification
so what did this do it it allowed for
the client to know that one it wasn't
the lab lab's fault and two that they
might have a problem in their facility
so continuing on with this
widespread contamination that client was
able to
determine that they had widespread
contamination of a pluralobacter species
in their facility and it was being it
was able to be conducted
in real time you know instead of weeks
of trying to figure this out we were
able to figure out in a couple of days
because of that they were able to
quickly
ask around and figure out what's been
going on in their facility
and come to find out
because they found this species in
different locations
they were able to narrow it down to the
fact that a
employee took a hose from one unit
transferred it to another unit without
cleaning it
and that's where the cam contamination
came from and that's how it spread
and so because of the biotaper we were
figuring this out in a couple days
versus a couple weeks
case study two colony confusion
client b sends in a food sample for
crohnobacter testing
well the method used for that uses
chromogenic chronobacter isolation order
or cci
and it's supposed to be chromogenic to
differentiate current vector species
from other organisms well as many might
know
selective augers always have the
exception organisms that will grow
and in this case the cci auger does
some enterobacter species franconifactor
species
and cystobacter species can have similar
colony morphologies on cci
to that of chronobacter well to
an untrained eye this looking at this
plate they're going to call it a
presumptive positive result
and that could be reported prior to
confirmation
what would this do well this would
involve further subculturing
isolation procedures it would extend
time of testing
it would freak out the client so what
were we able to do with the biotaper
we were able to quickly take a colony
off of that plate put it on the target
put it
into the instrument run it in you know
five to ten minutes and we get an
identification that says
enterobacter which then now we know it
is not
chronobacter and saves us lots of time
and energy than having to move on to
other traditional means
and lastly looking for legionella
siligenella
species causes legionnaires disease and
it can be tough to isolate
and identify especially because if the
methods aren't optimal for
legionella and water samples can yield a
wide range of organisms and if the
conditions are just right
legionella can be there so water systems
typically
have biofilms these biofilms contain
usually more than one organism
that grow on the surface and they're
very difficult to remove
so testing water from a system with a
biofilm makes it almost impossible to
isolate specific organisms
especially legionella because legionella
has to have optimal conditions
in order to grow so if you look at the
picture that's on this slide that is a
plate
um that we're looking for legionella on
you can see there's multiple different
colony morphologies on that plate
so for an analyst to look at that and
say ah yes there's legionella
it's very difficult so what is the
broker allowed
well we can grab some of those colonies
you know any morphology that looks
different throw it onto an ice
target place an instrument
you know again after 5 10 15 minutes
depending on how many isolates you have
on there we're able to get
identifications to show
that yes legionella is present or no
legionella is not present and that
that's
huge here it's it makes it so that
analysts don't have to spend so much
time
um you know researching and looking
at these plates and you're scratching
their heads saying like you know i just
don't know
or going to other traditional techniques
or means of identifications
to go through all of these calling
morphologies on this plate
so lastly i do want to point out
that the broker team has released their
newest technology
the ir bio typer to assist alongside the
broker multibiotyper for strain typing
so this technology actually allows for
you to compare isolates and determine if
they are the same strain
i will say that this is not a technology
that we
here at qlabs are familiar with yet
but it is definitely an exciting pop
possibility
to add to our microbial identification
toolbox
so overall what have we learned today
well the broker multi bio typer is a
powerful tool in our toolbox
that is proven to be a supreme
alternative to biological
and stereological options it's helped us
to determine the best solutions
for our customers and if that has and if
it hasn't been stressed enough
it allows for a quicker time to result
which in turn
allows for a faster decision making
for the laboratory and for the clients
so i appreciate everyone joining in
today and i hope that i have provided
you
a better understanding of mass stack
identifications and how
they can be implemented into the
contract laboratory setting
and now i'm looking forward to hearing
any questions that you may have at this
time
wow thank you wes for your informative
presentation
we are now going to start the live q a
portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the left side of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so let's get started we already have a
ton of questions in from the audience
here wes so let's start with this one
what do you do if you get a
no id so this is going to be one of
those instances where we're going to
look back
on the traditional ways of
identifications um so you're going to
look at your biochemicals
um and your 16s sequencing you know
whatever is going to work
for your laboratory or for that
situation with that isolate and client
another thing i know that we here at q
laboratories do is we're going to look
at the morphology of that isolate and
get it identified and if we notice that
this is
an isolate we commonly see then we
are going to look into adding that to
our custom library
so that in the future we don't have the
not real
the not reliable or the no
identification
great thank you so much moving on to our
next question
so how do i identify salmonella to the
ceravar
or species level using the smart
biotyper
so the biotyper is not going to be able
to identify to the ceravar it's just
going to be able to identify to the
genus so you'll get a result that just
says salmonella species
so then you're going to have to look
into other means for serology
antisera agglutination kits and things
like that
and what's our next question i am
getting no peaks even with the
extraction method
what could be the problem so this is a
great question
this is something that anyone who's run
mass spec technologies is going to run
into
so just some of the things that i know
on our end that we've
encountered that you want to check for
is first checking your target
plate that you're using broker has a
reusable stainless steel target as well
as disposable targets
um for the stainless steel targets over
time they can
wear and have scratches and things like
that
which could be some of the issues that
you're seeing with the nose
peaks um another thing is checking your
target spot where you've
placed uh your isolated colony uh
for uniformity you know make sure that
you're not you don't have bare areas
that are
just the stainless steel target without
the organism or matrix
you could be getting close to your
prevent maintenance
your annual pm and the laser could need
an optimization
in this case you just reach out to the
broker customer
customer assistance line they'll be able
to set up a webex
where with usually within about a half
hour
um where they'll remote in and they will
do a laser optimization and then they'll
be able to tell if
that was part of the problem and then
lastly something that you can do on your
end as an analyst is just making sure
that you're properly creating
any reagents that you're using
specifically your
formic acid solutions or your matrix
solution the matrix i know
it can be light sensitive and
can contaminate easy if you're not
reusing or
if you are reusing pipette tips so those
are
two areas on your end that you can
double check to see if there's any
issues there which could be causing your
no peek results
great wes thank you so much for your
insight on that question
um we're going to go back to something
that you mentioned about
testing older cultures i believe you
tested one up to
five days i think it was so regarding
testing older cultures
particularly bacterial cultures is there
any particular storage requirements for
these older plates
are they left at room temperature or are
they refrigerated
great question when we were validating
that we did
discover that in order to be able to
identify
cultures up to that five or seven day
mark
they did need to be held at room
temperature not refrigeration
great thank you so much so wes moving on
to our next question
um does it not affect takes in taking
the colony from any agar and
do we need isolated colonies
during the validation there were a wide
range of
um augers that were used generally
identifications
um are conducted off of a nutrient auger
general nutrient auger
but the we have seen
the selective augers that typical
methods use um you can run
identifications from them um and it is
key
for any identification not just with
mass spec but
it is key that you have an isolated
colony um
if if you have a mix if you have mixed
growth you're likely not going to get an
identification
and it can be kind of hard to pick out
if you have
um mixed growth so you just want to make
sure that you're really keeping a close
eye on getting those isolated colonies
great thank you now our next question do
you have a library for mycobacteria
yes broker does have a microbacterial
library
thank you now moving on
can we use colonies grown on selective
media
like bcye agar to id
on the maldi yes and that is one of the
great things um
again so typically nutrient auger is
used
for identifications but selective augers
specifically bcye is an auger that can
be used um
to get an id on the maori top similar to
case study three that i discussed
in the presentation that auger plate
that you saw was a bcy awkward plate for
legionella
and we were able to take colonies from
that plate and get identifications
now do do you use the ca version of
software the fda cleared
or the ruo and or what do you use both
currently we are using the ruo version
as well as
our custom library that we've created
from our in-house isolates
thank you now is it easy to add one
microorganism to the database
and do we need to validate that
it is very easy to add
an organism to your database um
the process um just i think the longest
part
in all honesty is just getting the
sequence the 16s sequencing
result that you need in order to add it
to the library
um but overall um it is
very easy um there's a couple of steps
you can usually add an isolate within
a half hour 40 40 minutes um to your
library
i'm sorry was there was your second part
to that question alexis
um is do we need to validate that that's
the second part
no on our end we did not have to
validate that process
uh when we added isolates to our library
perfect thank you so much now our next
question
is there is separate listeria spp
library or
is it included in the ruo or ivd
libraries
so the rui library that you will
people typically use has listeria
species as well as listeria
monocytogenes
in that library um but the subtyping
module
is just separate to where it kind of
breaks it down
even more with a little more accuracy to
give you
a better quality spectra and
identification
um since listeria species can be closely
related
and now can the type of culture media
affect the identification results
rarely like i said the best way to go is
usually a general
nutrient auger selective augers can be
used
i would suggest that if you're using a
selective auger
or chromogenic auger that if an
identification
uh if you're not able to achieve an
identification that i
suggest streaking to a general auger
after that
um and then trying again just to verify
um
because there are a lot of augers out
there and there's probably augers that
you might work with that i don't
um so i always like to do that as a
troubleshooting technique if i don't get
an identification
thank you moving on
sometimes we test atcc strains and we do
not receive a strain match on the top
hit
do you know what the cause of this could
be is this normal
um and we for some reason they're only
getting
cert uh certainty in genus and species
yes so when testing um you know qc
strains or streams that streams that
you're purchasing
um from culture collections
when you're running them on the burger
multi bio type or you're we're wanting
to verify that that's the organism that
you received
it might not show you the same strain
that's on there which could be due to
that strain not being
in the library but also the fact that
the biotyper is not
for strain typing is just for
identification
great thank you now do you do routine
detector checks on your instrument or
is this done only by broker engineers or
remote support
um typically i do not do any of that
here
if you're doing identifications and you
start to notice
that your log scores are
kind of decreasing in value or if you
have
any trouble with your calibration for
each run
um or you're getting a lot of no peeks
or anything like that then that's when
you're going to want to reach out like i
said before
to a broker customer customer service
assistant who can remote in and check
the detector and everything for you
thank you wes so we have time for a
couple more questions but i do want to
remind our audience
any questions that we aren't able to get
to and those submitted during the
on-demand
period will be addressed by our speaker
via the contact information that you
provided at the time of registration
um so wes moving on to
our next question what machine do you
use for sensitivity testing
and how do you perform qc on the
multibyte
on the multibio typer
so for qc on the multibiotyper
there is a calibration spot for each run
um using something called bacterial test
standard
um and that'll be with every single run
and during that it's
calibrating and validating that run if
anything were to happen
during the acquisition part of those two
spots
to where it wouldn't pass the qc
then the run would actually
automatically stop
um which would alert you that something
went wrong with your
calibration spots and that you would
have to re-spot them
and you know do a little troubleshooting
before getting identifications
thank you and now is there a broker
library for the
panawaya species yeah pantelia
species is in the reo library um as to
the extent of how many
art strains and species are in there i'm
not sure without looking at it but it is
in the library
great thank you now do customers request
that you build
library entries for their unidentifiable
organisms
or does q labs build an entry for
non-identifiable
organisms reflexively and the second
part to the question
is what sort of validation is performed
for these entries and approximately how
long until the entry is incorporated
into your routine identification
that's a great question so if a client
is routinely having
a contamination issue and
they want to keep a library of their
in-house isolates
and they are not being identified
um using the mollitov because they're a
wild type and because they're not or
because they're not in the library
then yes clients will ask us if we can
add those to our library but qlabs
does add reflexively to our library
because the analysts who are working
with the instrument every day and
running the isolates
have their eyes on these samples and are
able to see
routinely what's coming in and what's
going out
to add to that library and then
anything that's added to the library has
to be sent out for
16x 16s sequencing to verify what the
organism is
and then um will be added to the library
great thank you so much weston it looks
like we have time for one more question
how to proceed with the how do you
proceed with the yellow results that
have different genus
even after many times of purification
and that you know
it is a pure colony what is the
suggested
reporting action
for this instance this is where i would
suggest trying to figure out exactly
what information is needed
from a contract laboratory perspective
if we're running
an isolate and we get a genus level
identification
sometimes that's all the client will
need in terms of information and
therefore we don't need to
exhaust ourselves by running
the other extraction methods or running
it over and over
or having to send it out for sequencing
or anything like that
because the client just needs a genus
level um
if a species level identification is
needed and we
and we've exhausted all options in-house
you know
we've struck two different augers truck
one thing i can say that we'll try here
is
identify that organism at a younger age
it might just be that that
specifically isn't able to be identified
if it's an older culture
so you could try that but if all options
fail in-house
then that's when we're going to look
into other means of identification
such as 16s sequencing
thank you again wes for your time today
and for your important research
we would also like to thank levers and
our sponsor brooker deltonix for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
all of their interesting questions we
got a ton of them today so thank you
questions that we did not have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information that you provided at
the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
laborats will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time bye bye everyone